my name is silly not really well I'm
gonna play co-op but not today sorry we
could see it as ergh
whoa I actually take the right thing
what am I talking about all right we're
gonna play doctor mode dr. Jones Jones
wake up now dr. Jones Jones wake up now
dr. Jones Jones dr. Jones all right I
totally missed the story but here we are
and we are doctor
apparently this game this mod this
whatever it is it's really hard really
hard like I talked to rumbling I made it
and he said that you need to be like a
Korean to actually have a chance at this
is the progress probably no I'm not
really a try-hard anything like that but
I'm gonna put all my trihard face we're
gonna play this [ __ ] and wait I need
some inspirational music [ __ ] is it cold
oh yeah how can I forget the eye every
team guy can't have silly silly music in
the background man my bad BAM
hey buddy [ __ ] out yeah but it's bad
yeah come here [ __ ] it shoot you and
your bikes how the heck did I they're
not count come here buddy Oh
sink shot yeah yeah come here buddy I
shot your friend and he liked it he
liked it he liked it
stop slapping me your little shits right
in your face the second face trip off a
scare believe me I can't have it too
loud otherwise I'll get help
well what the hell is now back on the
street did my chest back off whoa whoa
I'm not through the [ __ ] he climbed
through [ __ ] I always wanted to do that
hey hey hey hey I know you're desperate
and I know you wanted fantasy [ __ ] off
come on the man dude dude he's like our
now was shooting me anyway ah [ __ ]
alright [ __ ] it
he's like my only weakness stabs the
crippled man [ __ ] this [ __ ] it's not a
good start
if Tiger pain oh good night my
nah dude hey how you doing
[ __ ] up whoa whoa crippled man no I'm
sorry I don't want to get copyright but
anyway how are you doing there we go
kill your friend wait there yeah no
friends
ha ha forever alone guy all right Wow
aloud to you to kind sirs I like the
best part is I'm not nearly done with
this and I don't think there's any
health packs if I understood things
correctly if your soy comprendo sick to
us on correcta all right be Nova and
Rubens mama Lady gaga running it for us
Oh Lady Gaga hello you know alright cool
cool cool stash your only weakness [ __ ]
off
oh no oh no they really like alright
we're good
I'm gonna sit down you're just gonna
chill over there don't shoot me
I see you over there Rubens dad don't
you dare don't you dad don't you dare
you little [ __ ]
he's still trying at least I know ice
giants hello i shooting your penis
actually miss so I probably got your
balls right okay all right let's go in
here like a bee for uas holy [ __ ] I mean
I I didn't even know Hey like a river
dance party what no no no no no no hey
hey I saw you you try to slap my butt
there we go like about like about like
about my mama
anyway the reason mostly the reason why
I'm playing this I know this is a really
horrible thing to let's play and romp
people told me to like do whatever you
can do a lot of quick saves and stuff
like that I don't really think that will
help
it will just be really live girl anyway
but I know that if I don't play this
everyone is gonna be like you have to
play producer whoa Ruben's mom you lost
some weight
oh [ __ ] oh whoa
she doesn't like water ah poor girl
shooter near prison that's what you get
you little [ __ ] stop crying it's only
alright so we're over here I think over
here there's some like extra bonus ammo
it's just my intuitions telling me this
and there will be nipple guys here guys
hey what and a dude to us and blah blah
blah blah [ __ ] off whoa he took the
shortcut don't you dare take a shortcut
are you stripping skills never fails
alright stop taking shortcuts
hey he died like a baby for you
speak your language that does not mean I
like you that's how I roll [ __ ]
alright bring it bring a door door a
vengeance see mo mo mo like a before you
all right we need to go where the [ __ ]
do I need to go I don't remember
again I came here yes got me this story
no it was but [ __ ] me okay
which door is it it's gotta be this one
alright I think it is not the rushing
time here actually rushing time that I
left behind
doo-doo-doo-doo let's do a save pew pew
pew pew pew
yes pick an easier name next time okay
why would I do that
all right how about Reuben stab how's
everyone doing in here I know one of
these doors hides like a camel thing sir
that's not this one see if you can nope
back off Oh emoji style right yes there
it is
alright let's kill all of these sons of
[ __ ] behind Sam Laura son Laura you
will be my put down I know I said but it
sounded good dick alright look at that
oblivious little guys like that doors so
sexy ah don't you dare try to molest a
wall door don't you dare that's what you
get I thought there were more here oh
there they are like when you comes in
air we got a [ __ ] oh no you're not
no you're not whoa how did you survive
that that is amazing
there we go oh no I wasted how at a bar
alright let's say pew pew and make it
easier for yourself you got to think
twice
alright here's the problem cuz I have
that those little [ __ ] and I just
stop being in bed holy [ __ ] and it's
gonna run for it again
alright not bad so far not bad at all so
I call myself a sir
I'm just gonna play until I die I guess
I don't really know I would probably die
any second Oh Marsh no Giants hello hi
FLN by the look of him he doesn't look
very good so you just keep dressed chill
out here that's what you do it's how you
roll container to your Bing yeah got him
call him later I think at least hey just
gonna hey don't try to follow me hey hey
I might consider joining okay ugh fine
I'm going and going
sorry for interrupting here gang meeting
or whatever that was don't know what it
was probably let's go here rising up
back on the street did my time took my
chances
oh oh oh where do subscribe ah it's
gonna be me relax here fortunes me
listen I know your hair my luck it's my
sexual sounds it attracts murlocs you
use those sounds to track your dog [ __ ]
is wrong with you
alright
meh relax ah yes here let's say pew all
right
I think police bill is here whoa all
right I need to shoot him
I need to shoot him ah here but it's
been but it's been are you talking now
what's he saying I don't speak Felicity
whoa whoa whoa whoa
all right Marilyn I'm out of here Mara
Lux
nice chatting with you
but does see you later
pretty good fire I only lost half of my
health and I probably have a long way to
go but that's cool that's cool that's
very cool not cool at all whoa I think I
need a reload I think there's another
one coming here brace for impact face
yes what you get for being American
whoa I didn't expect that someday whoa
quadratus CC okay cut it out nipple you
guys happens all the time
actually it's quite rare and we are
lucky to see it all right
I think I can strafe skills the ones
that goes here all right bring it Wow
Wow
[ __ ] you whoa stay straight straight
from my bed shot all right I hope
there's no room is mom here get Finn
it's gonna be a Reuben mom here we good
all right cool I don't know if I lose
the ammo if I reload I don't know it
shouldn't cause it's a revolver it's not
like an entire clip or anything I don't
really know how it works let's check
over here oh dude oh no I died no rest
ah it's it from the beginning
oh yeah you see I had the same things I
had them but anyway that is pretty much
the doctor mode if you want to tries
have fun with it
but I don't think I'll complete it to be
honest unless you bros really wanted me
to we'll see I just wanted to shut up
I'm talking here that's pretty much it
like favorites you enjoyed another thing
I want to tell you baby there's gonna be
like custom stories for cry of fear just
like there is cousin stories for amnesia
so if you want to make one I would be
happy to play it probably gonna be
difficult but I think they're pretty
cool rompers gonna make one as well that
he says is gonna be scary as hell so
looking forward to that so you know this
is definitely the not let a subscribe
here that you will see there's also the
co-op that coming out with the secret
you to bear some of you already know who
it is and that's pretty much it it's not
a boys crack if it's okay
now I have about see that damn bud goes
[Music]
how's everyone doing in here uh tree